thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another great episode of
careful boys today we have Nikki with us
hello hello
and if you notice the chair she's
sitting in that means welcome back to
hot tea we have the hottesty and the
hottest questions
because in honor of him and you being in
the seat I'm gonna do it his way thank
you what's that mean hot seed um he does
his boring style I do this yourself
we start off extremely chilled Bart take
it away oh [ __ ] okay is it okay if I
lean back like this it's not too far
back I just hope that thing doesn't
break not because you're a fat no not
not because you stop touching it because
you're fat probably heavy that chair is
a little wobbly it took a beating it's a
launcher okay got it at the end of the
day be careful
it's in a prop actually
I mean that's so real this is my Discord
uh avatars me in this chair anyway yeah
oh nice
um
let's say you were trapped inside of a
mango oh okay on a counter
this is a riddle Steve doesn't know how
would you get Steve the mushrooms to
save you
from the mango if I was trapped in a
mango on the kitchen counter how would I
get Steve to save couple other mangoes
around you too how big is this mango am
I just a tiny person that's it that's it
that's it mango I don't know you have to
start speak that on the counter Steve
would pretty much be like what the [ __ ]
is this huge makeup too and I could
probably put like help me bust out I'm
not sure I would notice it
an elephant sized mango all the mangoes
are the same size in a ruffle like that
so I'm like an Indian other version
regular mango yeah when you're in the
mango
the mango okay say native American now
but that's not the title of the book I'm
just saying it's what you got to say
okay if we could make this question go
for five minutes by the way that'd be
great we just want to make sure
everyone's clicked away and then we'll
keep okay okay how do you get Steve to
rescue you you've been kidnapped by
mango
um
like can you hear me in the mango oh
okay
say no say no actually change it
[Applause]
oh this make us talking and I'd be like
no it's me you [ __ ] idiot I'm trapped
in a mango and he's looking at the
cupboards don't cut me
evil like don't
[ __ ] white
I put her down the garbage disposal she
said don't put food on the garbage
disposal this is irony I don't want to
exist anymore thanks for helping me
oh man this is an interesting Aussie
though do you like mangoes I love
mangoes that's good that's good keep my
way out of it before Steve helps see
that's a better solution
do you eat mangoes uh it's not my
favorite and then I'd berate him about
how I had to eat myself out of a mango
because he couldn't save me that's
correct so how's your relationship been
these days I [ __ ] love it that's cool
because that's not what I saw I saw him
complaining about pillows and stuff yeah
and then I was like it's like you know
you know in like first of all countries
where you have it good like you have it
so good that you have to look for things
to complain about yeah that's him okay
well turn up or not just a little bit
what's the last thing you guys thought
about oh yeah that's a good question
like to like legitly thought about not
like just any bickering something that
could bring those emotions back so we
could see it recreated it'd be dramatic
it could be not traumatic how big
Steve's penis is oh oh this morning
um I wanted to curl my hair in the in
the and he was like it's 9 40. I'm like
that's way more enough time than for me
to curl my hair he's like just do it
while you're at JK I was like I don't
want to JK it takes a long time to heat
up don't you know anything about curling
irons he said no I don't you're right
you curl your hair so he lost that fight
oh that's why Nick got here earlier than
him which I was ready I was packed ready
to go I had to curl my hair and pack my
bag
because at 9 45 that's when you kind of
want to look how's it going okay here at
10. are the household chores split
pretty evenly between you two no he just
most of them know [ __ ] it's because
why are you such a Sim like the first
five years I feel like I did most of
them and then it kind of like I kind of
cried so much about having to do all of
it so then he's slowly started taking
over yeah there's nothing to do with the
fact that you make more money than him
now
that's 100 and Anthony I didn't want to
oh
quickly because I have autism
make money at all
he makes Bitcoins it doesn't cash out
and they go down but they're not real
Bitcoins they're alt coins yeah and they
go way down I'm not real pictures
there's other kinds of coins
they're the the phobic course he makes
money on JK and then he spends it all on
hotels
by the way because people are gonna
think that's real like
no it's real yeah
completely realized so much more money
so you say you haven't been here like
two years a serious question in the two
years from whatever you've seen from
afar how do you feel about the attitude
area what's the attitude oh no you know
about it
yeah
a little bit hurt but okay that's a good
answer yeah yeah the [ __ ] did you call
me what did you call her I don't call
her looking at this camera angle
uh I don't watch the show so I don't
know I haven't really observed that much
um that's what that's what the guests
always say and we believe all women I
told Ray anime over here I really like
his reels like I didn't watch I never
watched JK even when I was on it but
I've been watching the wheels have been
popping up on my Instagram and they're
really funny yeah and I actually like
giggled out loud a few times but I
wouldn't giggle at the real show just
the real of course of course that's why
there's more subscribers on that one
which real is your favorite
question mine's a better question okay
okay I think you're gonna waste time
like that honestly the type
oh
you've been asked questions
she actually went and watched the whole
video after that I did no I did no so
the videos work my butt yeah
that's a good one
the best gift we've ever had honestly
yeah so it's a better question mark ask
your dumbass question is recently you
had a big career
how has that been and how has like your
family re received it and all that
because it's like it's big yeah oh it is
boring well I mean yeah that I I was
actually surprised my dad said he was
proud of me wow has only said one time
in my life when I was 26 that was the
first time he ever said it we were at uh
about to go to a premiere of a show that
I was in that got nominated for
something in New York and we were in New
York and and he said it and I was like
right before I was about to go in the
carpet and I didn't know how to process
it and I was like ah and so I just like
shut it down and then this was like the
second time he said it he was like he
was like I'm really proud of you you
really are an amazing person and he put
it in the family chat oh that's a flex I
picture your dad going like when he did
that Gate Theater stuff man I wasn't
sure but when you're doing poker that's
my baby girl no yeah your dad's the
white one no Filipino Filipino that
means so much it really did holy [ __ ]
you never believe white men well and
he's also probably the reason I have
imposters said no I mean not the reason
sorry Dad but like
but like uh like I never think like
every anything's like really that good
like that I do like I never you never
got that validation yeah and it was like
you don't know like it was always kind
of expected to be like a better like
academically got straight A's that's
what you're supposed to do you're not
it's no not a big deal like nothing's a
big deal right and so but I think he
played sports for so long he was a
baseball player and so he was used to
like like baseball articles like my
brother would get written up in the
paper all the time for his football
plays and stuff and so when uh poker
news came out with a bunch of Articles
like when they were like doing real time
um articles of what was happening in the
tournament he I he was able to read
those and even though he didn't
understand the terminology he got that
it was like a sport and then I was like
doing highlighting the coverage story
yeah yeah it was wild really cool and
they're like out of nowhere yeah my
whole family was watching her live like
they were pulling up on their TVs
because you can do that that's [ __ ]
cool and they're watching her like live
what was all going on no idea that so
many people were watching either we were
here watching well in every break we
would see the score yeah we would be on
the virtual wsops yeah yeah that was
really that was really uh we're like oh
[ __ ] going up in the she's
great game
that's the biggest part I played so many
games with you on JK party but I've
never seen like a poker face yeah I
think Mafia was probably the closest
example see like that with like like
you're like the shot was like across the
table I'm like oh that's pretty gangster
yeah yeah that was cool my coach said
that his favorite part and they did this
at this latest tournament we were all in
in San Antonio he's like my favorite
part is that like whenever you're all in
like you'll just shove on somebody and
take your phone out and just be like
like she's like that's so scary like
you're just like I don't give a [ __ ] do
it call me and I'm just like filming it
the whole time oh you're filming yeah
yeah like I was filming up for insta
stories Oh I thought I thought you were
playing Angry Birds
so I'd be like all in sometimes she has
uh earrings on that says call me so
gangster which in poker is obviously
hilarious yeah and then she has a
sweatshirt that says folding is boring
that's actually a ramp it's great full
thing is wait you're allowed to pull
your phone on just like record people
playing like while you're playing wow
that's crazy that's got to be
intimidating it's right that makes sense
well this is the 10 minute and 17 second
Mark that where uh we actually got some
submitted questions by fans yeah so um
uh this is uh submitted by Steve's
hairline
um when Steve's Grandpa kiss you on the
lips what are you really thinking
that's true I don't think that happened
waiting on the lips
I blocked it from my memory what did you
feel like in love a little bit I was
like this is what it's gonna be like in
50 years with my husband oh you weren't
like that's how it's like to be with a
real man I was like I gotta get him on
the alcohol and on the cigars and then
it'll be exactly like what it'll be like
okay all right second question submitted
by uh Steve's Rebrand
um on a scale of one to ten ten being
lustfully amazing how hot is Steve's
sister actually
how did you ever resist that she made me
question my sexuality really I've never
taken a hot shower my whole life were
you intimidating at thanks were you
intimidated at Thanksgiving yeah I was I
was shaking I was busy like every time I
picked up a drink I was just like damn
please don't
don't look over there
sorry she's a married woman my sister
was in was a maid of honor and I almost
accidentally married my sister
okay follow-up questions submitted by um
all coins uh if you couldn't marry any
other tuber who would it be
great question I don't watch YouTubers
or from maybe from our generation then
from our generation like that'd be like
a shame who do I need to kill yeah to
really just watch poker vloggers so
probably one of the poker vloggers I
know
School poker vloggers uh Vlog I mean the
poker guys Vlog like Phil Ivey or
whatever's no well uh negranu does oh
really yeah he probably has always been
on he has a yeah he is probably one of
the biggest
um Vlogs and streams our poker vloggers
actually good at poker I think so yeah
oh I mean there's a lot it's just like
how there's a lot of YouTubers like our
YouTubers actually good at YouTube well
a small selection are because a lot of
YouTubers in that genre actually suck
ass at the genre you mean like a
basketball YouTuber YouTube part of it
well yeah I mean there's a lot of cool
like okay Rampage for example the one
that says the folding is boring
sweatshirt he started at one three and
he like is kind of like loose aggressive
and he rose through the ranks so now
he's playing like these huge like 100
200 High Roller cash games and so people
like following the journey
well just to give you some perspective
one three like it's like a couple
hundred bucks and what did you say 100
200. yeah so that means like when you're
playing these games you might wait
dollars yeah so when you play these
games you might win like 50 bucks here
30 bucks there 100 bucks here if you're
lucky maybe a couple hundred right but
and maybe you'll go up to a thousand who
knows but that's like when it's wild but
when you're going like 100 to what
what's the 300 yeah like like 100 200
yeah that could be like 10 000 in one
game yeah well more than that because
the buy-in for 100 200 like if you're
buying 100 big blinds would be 20 grand
oh [ __ ] yeah oh that's just the buy-in
like 100 big Blends is like pretty much
the minimum that you would want to buy
in for at a cash game eight or nine
people at a table and they're all if
they all put in yeah yeah so like most
of the buy-ins are like six figures each
yeah holy [ __ ] so there's like a million
dollars on the table and [ __ ] and like
wow yeah and you're [ __ ] playing
Angry Birds you're gangster what was um
what's your top three least favorite
things about when you were on JK news
um when we'd have like stories that were
uh like I couldn't
maybe like I don't know they were too
political or they're too serious like I
don't know I I don't like I don't really
like to comment and because I don't know
anything about the story and then
sometimes you're like you're just saying
your First opinion because it's based
off the information you're hearing and
then later you find out there's like a
whole bunch of information that you
didn't hear about and people are mad at
you I didn't like things like people
like there's just a lot of people that
get mad at you and I'm like man I'm just
going off of what's happened in the
conversation we don't know like I don't
read the article beforehand like people
just neither do we you're like hey this
guy fell off a building and you know
landed on five kids and they all died
and I'm like oh damn that's really sad
like well did you actually know that
those kids but well actually rob the
bank first
I don't know
those kids actually headbutted the guy
yeah but you'll be you'll be um pleased
to know that doesn't have as much now
like people don't get as Madness like
those people are kind of gone because
most people are gone so yeah it works
don't challenge them to come back
we made a good effort of weeding them
out yeah most viewers what are the other
two we did such a good job that you
don't even watch the show anymore yep I
never did watch the show them out all
right that makes you feel better I never
watched it no but the community is a lot
better like they're really really nice
yeah that was probably number one number
two uh I don't know I guess they're like
long hours there's like oh yeah back
then wasn't it I mean these are pretty
long hours but it was long I mean there
was like 40 episodes a day those days
were long it would get out like 10
so that's the other thing too is like by
the end of the day you're just like
barely a lot
of brain is like a bush pot right now a
poor management leadership day three of
this I don't know I don't [ __ ] know
nothing I don't even remember what the
words are that are coming out of my
mouth and then we would still go out
together and eat that's nice and talk
for another two hours that was the fun
part the and then number three
um it was called
that's true yeah this office whatever it
is if it's hot outside it's hot in here
if it's cold outside it's cold enough
insulation problem so it's not really
like we have walls at all well this
isn't exactly supposed to be office
space and I think we all know that all
right this is like a warehouse It's a
loading zone
we got neighbors doing rebar yeah the
guy comes in he's like I got like 5 000
feet of rebar I'm so [ __ ] sorry
we're gonna be moving it up and down all
day what do you guys doing here I have a
question so like when we met you
um you were alive 2015. super old school
times that's like what seven years ago
at least yeah and then
um we were all like deep in
entertainment YouTube and we had that
career trajectory of like going into
traditional yeah media somehow and then
so like we all dabbled in many different
things and now you're kind of like fully
full force with being poker Queen so
like how was that Journey for you and
then did you like ever
did that settle in like okay I'm I'm not
doing YouTube no more or like I'm not
doing it in this way no more or like
yeah that was kind of crazy because uh
because I feel like I'm like one foot
out one foot in like I I didn't really
commit yet to being like this is a new
route I want to take but it just keeps
going that way so I'm like oh like I
mean I like I like just follow like
what's pulling me
um
I uh I wanted to just get away from
everything like I just at one point I
just was sick of being looked at like I
just like people think they want to be
famous or whatever I never wanted to be
famous but I like wanted people to like
my work you know and like be known for
my work and it just gets to a point
sometimes like and I get it like there's
this influencer community that like
there's not like the greatest of egos in
it and so you kind of all get lumped in
one category and then everyone just like
kind of hates you and judges you and
does all this stuff and and it's a you
have to have people watching you in
order to continue creating and making a
living doing it but you also have like a
bunch of people judging you and hating
you and I just didn't like all the
energy on me anymore so I started
playing poker just like to kill time and
be like just like to hide almost like
just to be away from everything like and
I I was like I liked going to the
casinos because no one knew who I was
like you wear a mask at the time because
it was during like a pandemic and so and
sunglasses no one knows no zero people
know who I am even if they even if I
didn't have the mask on nobody in that
room would know who I was and so it was
just kind of like ah like no I can just
be me and like I can just like play a
game and the cards don't know anything
about you the cards just like they don't
care it's just a game people are playing
and like I just like that and then we
moved to Vegas and I started playing
more and playing more and then I didn't
even play tournaments at the beginning
of this year and then I started playing
tournaments and then I was doing well
with them and then uh now I'm like super
involved in the poker Community I really
love it nobody knows you and it's a
vicious cycle it's gonna happen again
it's not like a destination it's more
like oh it's kind of a place that you
just kind of fell into and you kept
going yeah and I like I love the
community like it just feels so much
like people that understand me and I get
them and they get me as a lot of ADHD
people and and people that just like um
they think the same way and they're very
in into like individual individual and
they don't think they don't prejudge
everything like so polarized that like
it's not like left right political like
you know how like in the real world like
people just get so polarized in poker in
that Community it's very like I think
because you're analyzing so much in the
game like you're analyzing a lot of
situations and so people or more issues
based than they are like it does not
gambling but like just that world yeah
it does have a bunch of people who are
more like these things don't matter yeah
because it's like yeah like also playing
games like that you start to understand
human psychology
a lot better but yeah I know what you
mean it's like and then also it brings
everyone together yeah because you're
playing a 10 hour game and you might be
some hardcore liberal next to like some
hardcore Trump supporter but you you're
like playing the same game you like
poker a lot and then you just might be
like well this guy's a human and I'm a
human and yeah let's take his money yeah
and I could take it yeah they just like
talk to the conversations involved like
no one's so aggro about anything like
everyone's kind of just like yeah we're
almost Casino together like we're all in
this card room
on the same level yeah but I did tell my
manager at one point because I was going
on a lot of auditions and I was like
don't send me out anymore like I don't
when was that during covid
um right before kovid actually and then
like let me go poke them it kind of was
like yeah this is the correct Choice and
then um we moved to Vegas and I told
them that I got that I was getting
really into poker like this is way
before there's like way last year early
last year and um I was like yeah I'm
getting into poker if you know any like
more poker related because I wanted to
do more like media hosting I still want
to do this more like commentating and
like media hosting for poker and I
noticed that a lot of the people that or
media hosting they they weren't like
also players they were just like hosting
and I was like I didn't understand the
game like yeah like they knew maybe knew
a little bit about the game but like
there wasn't a like I noticed a lack of
of that so I was like maybe I could
combine the Two Worlds something that
I'm good at that's something that yeah
yeah
it was really fun did you can commentate
like yeah in style and understand the
game but you're also entertaining and
she does it she does it on Twitch like
every Sunday and I watch it like avidly
like she's like talking about the hands
and like why she's doing what she's
doing and I'm not even interested in
playing poker but I'm interested in
watching poker and it's fun watching her
play poker like it's just that's a good
host it's really yeah exactly a good
host will make something you're not
interested in be really fun and she
explains the game like she cares about
it so I always like listening to people
who are passionate about something like
it's fun so yeah she's a great advocate
for it thanks guys that's really cool do
you want to ask the hottest question of
the uh session Anthony you're always
good at that yeah it's Steve's question
is would you rather [ __ ] yours your mom
or your dad both because to see if it's
your mother-in-law your father-in-law no
my mother-in-law father-in-law well I
probably [ __ ] your dad because
um he has a penis
like I love your mom but I just don't
want to be next to a vagina well I'm
just gonna swallow do you think that he
you stay hard longer than you
yeah I do
JK like you've been around for a minute
but there is a new era that you have to
be inducted in and we have to make sure
that you're old enough for kisses the
last question is are you a fan of Clint
Eastwood
um I did see this clip on the I think it
was on the reels no you didn't it's
Ryan's fault because he put it in the
reels you said you never she never
admitted that she told she never told me
that she saw it wait yes moment is
ruined
I I I personally am old enough for
kisses
[Music]
foreign
[Music]